when should someone quit their job to
become a filmmaker as soon as you can
you know because I mean think about it
like what the rule of thumb is going to
takes 10,000 hours to master your craft
and the longer you take to get those
hours the longer it's gonna take to
really kind of get a handle on this
because directing takes a lot of time it
takes a many many many years to like
really understand all the aspects of the
business so I know at first it could be
a challenge you know cuz you're fresh
out of school or whatever but as soon as
you can get okay I know when I first
started it was really hard for me cuz I
was working I was working at a computer
repair center and I knew that every hour
I was spending there is one hour I was
not spending on set or writing or
whatever Windows 95 I believe it was
that was where I saw my first one
gigabyte hard drive so like but I
remember sitting in the the break room
at lunch time I would sit there and I'd
look out the window and I'd see all the
cars going past me knowing they're all
going somewhere and I was not you've got
to get out of that as fast as you can't
find some way to make a living in this
business as quickly as you possibly can
even if it's piaying on you know some
big whatever on the smallest movie ever
you're practicing least you're on the
ladder least you're you're observing
filmic even if you're catering you're on
the set you're watching the action it
doesn't matter get there somehow as fast
as you possibly can before school even
while you're in school even better you
know I mean there's there's people of
interning for me who are high school
students which I'm like man I wish I
could have done that in high school it
would put me so far ahead yeah yeah and
if you could find a way to make a living
in some aspect of this industry do it
how'd you leave that job it was I got to
a point where I just couldn't do it
anymore
it just hit a breaking point like I had
I had to go and I saw wasn't an
opportunity it was just someone
suggesting I move to a new city where
stuff was being made
and so abandoning all I went and they
started my life like it it was worth it
it was hard I had no friends was on the
other literally on the other side of the
country diagonally from where I was and
I did change everything got it all
started did you ever think oh I should
have stayed there for like just a first
week not once not once it yeah
it's that's the thing about there's
terror and moving plate you know it's
relocated it's a leaving everyone mind
there's a fear in that but you know as
soon as you do it even when you land
it's usually like yeah I this is a good
thing
you know that's usually the question for
LA for a lot of people should I move to
LA or whatever and that's the that's the
fear that you're gonna regret once you
get there I don't know I feel like most
people don't
a few leave but I feel like most people
probably don't you know I should say
something about LA the LA mentality the
LA thing everyone who doesn't live in LA
probably on some level asks and wonders
if they should live in la la it's not
the answer to everything it all depends
on what you want to do there is this
funny belief this is what I hear people
say a lot I'll come to LA when I need to
they'll say that and they'll say I'll
fly in for any meeting now that is
predicated on this belief that the break
comes down to them eating well that's
hey at the end that can be where it
happens you know you have the meeting
that changes everything but what you're
you're not realizing is is that there's
a build-up to that it's a who you know
industry and if you're trying to get
into those upper echelon at work you
have to know the right people and it
that is not at the meeting that happens
at someone's birthday party
that happens at you know I meant I
wanted to play paintball with a buddy a
week ago and I met out several industry
people that could totally make my
here you know that we could go like at
paintball like that's not the kind
you're gonna fly in for right that's
that's the importance of relationships
and believe me it matters who you know I
don't care how talented you are if you
don't know anybody your road is gonna be
long and hard someone asked me once a
long long time ago if they thought I
worked they said do you think you've
worked harder than JJ Abrams and that
was a tough question cuz I was like and
I didn't live in LA at the time and I
thought no I don't think I have I think
that we've probably both worked very
hard just as hard cuz I I work very hard
well then what is it about him that puts
him where he is and me where I am well
his dad was in the industry and he was
editing home videos for Steven Spielberg
when he was in high school that he was
groomed to be where he is now I'm not
saying he didn't earn it he's worked
very hard clearly he's very good at what
he does but he knew the right people
that is that changes your career right
there you have to live if you want to be
in those upper echelon zand things you
better live here if you're fine with not
working in that then you don't have to
come that's kind of what it comes down
to
you